real quick before I start this video I
just wanted to credit a friend he gave
me the idea for this entire video so
make sure you go over to the video I
linked in the description and give it a
like what is going on guys welcome to
another video brought to you by
statistically challenged today we are
going to be taking 1 GPA singular artist
coin and seeing how much money we can
make in exactly one hour only using
these shops located in varrock so
without further ado let's get right to
it
I've already got the stopwatch open I
hope you guys enjoyed this video and I
hope we make a decent amount let's get
to it
the first stop is the general store
because this is the only place you're
gonna be getting an item for 1jp so I
decided to buy a jug we're gonna go
right to the GE and sell this keep in
mind we're not gonna be using any
stamina plots or teleports so this is
gonna be only using our feet and run
energy um so there's gonna be a lot of
walking in the future I I'm a guessing
and we're gonna get a grand total of 2
GP nice so that was definitely not the
right call we're gonna go back and we're
gonna find something that isn't complete
trash I'm gonna head up to the store
here the clothing store and a pink
skirts 2gp and it goes for a tgp Wow
that is an insane profit let's head in
and see if it actually sells for what it
promises alright so wow it actually sold
for 85
although we are gonna be walking now we
are at 2 minutes and 12 seconds
and we've made 85 GP so far not bad ok
we're back at the general store I just
want to check out a few items because I
think that I really [__] up the first
time you get a tinderbox and
let's get a bucket and a chisel and the
cheese is only 15 pots 4gp your box is
57 that's actually not a bad margin
we're gonna resell the pawn the chisel
and it didn't get [__] for that I
actually had zero GPU for selling those
so all we gonna do now is just probably
buy a bunch of pink skirts because these
seem to be the best so far let's see the
apron we'll get one of those
I'm guessing this [__] goes for nothing
yeah okay so the apron is 58 well give a
silks garbage it seems to be worth it to
only buy the pink skirts and maybe even
these blue skirts so I'm gonna pink
skirts and blue skirts and then probably
just world top okay never have I thought
I'd be walking around with this
inventory but we've got the pink skirts
the tinderbox both the apron colors I'm
not sure which one's gonna sell for more
an actually ran out of space I still
have six EGP left but we're going to the
GE and I hope we get a big profit here
okay we're just gonna sell the rig in
the dump the brown apron so swatch for
50 each so we have 1.7 Kate and it's
been 6 minutes and 25 seconds let's go
right back I'm just trying to think of
shops that might be good here I think a
pretty good idea of what I want to do
next though and we find ourselves at the
archer shop here I think we can get some
pretty good profit off the arrows so the
irons go for 8 the bronze only go for 4
and they're like 7 in the G so we're
gonna hop world's here let's see if we
can get some better prices for the
bronze arrows yes is what I'm talking
about
it 1gp that's like we just gets 6gp
profit every bronze 0 so we're just
gonna buy it on these out and just keep
world hopping that actually been take
too long how much are these 700 got 5.2
K for 749 bronze arrows we just pretty
much multiplied our money by 5 there and
I didn't take long at all let's go sell
these real quick
and the grand total is 4 point 4 K okay
we didn't actually get some GP for each
arrow
we're at the 10-minute mark we're at 5 K
about so let's go back and just stock up
on it as much [__] as we can before
going back to the bronze arrows I'm just
gonna keep buying these pink skirts
until my inventory is full and then when
I have one in the toy slot left I'm just
gonna use the rest of the cash on the
bronze arrows this way I think it's just
more efficient in general because the
pink skirts every time you buy a pink
skirt you make like a t3 GPA so it's
pretty nice and I'm just buying steel
arrows now I realized that their margins
are pretty good they go for 35 on the GE
and it doesn't take as long to buy them
as bronze arrows so it's 10k right there
my inventory we're at the 13 minute mark
let's see if it actually sells for what
it's showing in the price checker so
yeah yeah I'll get back to you guys
after I go sell this stuff after
collecting and selling everything we've
managed to accumulate 9.5 K checking the
timer now we are approximately at the 14
minute 48 second mark which is pretty
good they were just gonna get out there
and buy some more stuff I've decided
that I'm just gonna use everything
unlike bronze arrows bonds IRA seem to
have the best margin at this point and
they're very they're very fast it's like
buying them is very fast they're usually
always in stock at every world so I'll
get back to you guys one of these on my
catch
we finally bought all the bronze arrows
and we're walking back to the GE now if
you're wondering about what these beers
in my inventory are I thought it'd be a
good idea but it's actually [__] buying
beers A to G pH and selling them for I
believe they're gonna sell 70 or
something like that anyways it's not
worth it at all we're just gonna sell
all this [__] and go right back to the
arrows because that's where the money's
at so real quick change of plans I'm
actually gonna be buying death rooms
with all the cash because the margins
seem to be pretty nuts in the end I
don't think it's gonna be worth it
because I'm gonna be making like 5k and
I'd to go all the way back to the GE
it's like no run energy so it does burn
a lot of time we're just gonna
experiment a little and use like other
shops than just the arrows we're walking
back with about a hundred and four death
runes and I have no idea what the [__]
is following me behind me just a bunch
of people holding gnome balls
anyways let's see what this goes for I'm
not too impressed that was really lame I
didn't make that much offset at all in
red League 31 minute mark
with only 25k can we turn this around in
the next 30 minutes we'll see
since I actually have a lot more money
now I'm gonna be buying out steel arrows
their GP margins are about 10 - like 15
which is pretty good the only thing
that's bad about these is that you top
constantly and since you have to help so
many times to burn 20k cash you do get
reattempt into logged in screens which
pretty much it kicks you to the login
screen if you have too many times you're
just gonna buy all these out and see
what happens
it took a while but let's sell all this
and we should see a nice profit yup and
we have 38 K 38 minutes on the timer so
not bad guys it's not bad let's go back
and see what we can do I just realized
that SAFF has a staff shop here and
there are battle staffs and these normal
staffs beside them in the shop actually
they really they suffer one came word
that GE so I'm just gonna keep buying
these the good thing about this is that
I don't have to hop 50 times to burn the
cash stack and the GE is right beside
this shop so I think this might be where
we make a lot of money so that took like
2 minutes I bought all the staffs and
take many World Cups and we just made
like 10k profit wow that was actually
really good yeah they sell for 8.7 K buy
them for like seven point four K we're
just gonna keep doing this this we just
found the jackpot so I am quite a few
trips in and I realized that since I
can't buy another staff because there's
7.4 ok I'm just gonna come here and buy
some more arrows with a remaining cash
file to be more efficient although I
don't think this is more efficient I
think if you just buy the battle stabs
you make more money but we'll see
all right we have so much [__] in our
inventory let's sell all this these
stabs these normal stabs don't actually
sell anymore but the battle sounds are
still making a scrape profit the arrows
are always nice and after we sell
everything after a few trips we have 78k
these stabs are garbage we're just gonna
dump
we're still getting 130 GPS on that Wow
we've 78k and we have already in route
49 minutes so we have ten more minutes
let's see if we can break white cash and
we're just gonna sell these eleven nice
we aren't having a hundred and eleven K
we broke the white cash mark and we are
at 56 minutes guys I only have another
trip or two
ZAF stop is really good because it's
close and make the trips fast plus the
margins on these [__] battles staves
are like they're pretty crazy I mean
this is just good if you have a big
amount of cash this can make you a lot
of money all right we're done another
inventory and 132 K while that took like
no time at all the problem is that these
these are actually bought out quite
frequently on all the worlds I'm
assuming other people do this but we are
at 15 minutes and we have about one more
inventory to go and we will be done this
challenge so let's get this inventory
over with real quick
looks like this will be the last world
top of the video and to get one staff
yeah they're bought out a lot that is
the one hour mark let's head back to the
G and see what the final profits are and
after spending one hour from one GP only
xing shops in varrock we have managed to
make 146 k there is the time where once
again I do not recommend this to anybody
this is just a fun challenge I wanted to
do but as you can see from one GP you
can actually make some cash you know
it's like buy some room
alright let the money we just made we're
just gonna go to world one and drop all
these room axes to a mini drop party
because it's just 146 K and other makes
some free-to-play scrubs just a little
happier so I hope some people make some
bunk so while all these people loot all
these rune X's I'm just going to do the
outro to the video right now if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure to leave a
like a comment and even subscribe if you
want to see some more content from me
this challenge I do not recommend to do
for a money maker but if you actually
have nothing else to do and you have one
GP and you want to make some quick cash
just do this it's not the best money but
it's something to start with until next
time I hope you guys all have a good day